Also, is yellow, technically a binder and will it bind to other minerals and things in my body?
Should we be taking it away from food and other supplements?
Which is taking any key later?
So my definition that between a key later and a binder is the binder stays in your gut,
the key later is absorbed. Now there's a lot of things that act as binders in your gut and will
cross the gut border and act as key later in your tissue. So is it better to take all key later
slash binders away from food? Well, in a perfect world? Yes. And away from other supplements,
get a perfect world? Yes. Is it always necessary? Is it always realistic? No. But yeah, in a perfect
world it will be better to take all key later and all binders away from other food.
Sometimes it's a very difficult for a keeper. So I don't always state that or do state it
and all the binders that are state in your gut to take those away from food.